varian indien qui s'installe tout
doucement on l'aura compris en france
donne évidemment des sueurs froides à
bien des gouvernements sur toute la
planète clairement il fait planer la
menace d'une quatrième vague est la
rentrée on vient de le dire alors se
mariant delta va t'il nous pourrir l'été
en france
est-ce que la traque est suffisante
sommes nous en train de reproduire les
mêmes erreurs que l'été dernier c'est
l'objet de notre décryptage ce soir et
pour en parler nous sommes avec philippe
froguel chercheur généticien professeur
à l'impérial college de londres et à
l'université lille 2 merci beaucoup
philippe froguel d'être avec nous à vos
côtés en direct de bruxelles laurent
alexandre essayiste et chirurgiens
bonsoir à vous aussi laurent alexandre
merci infiniment d'être avec nous ce
variant delta ça y est on reparle du duc
o vie des parents bien évidemment fo cgc
rarement en bien d'ailleurs quand on
parle de ce virus
il représente entre 9 et 10% des
contaminations en france c'est ce
qu'elle dit le porte parole du
gouvernement aujourd'hui ça vous paraît
laurent alexandre être le bon chiffre où
on est en dessous de la réalité
je partage complètement l'avis du
professeur fragueules sur le fait qu'on
ne sait quand ce pas assez les virus en
france
donc nous avons des approximations au
lieu d'avoir des chiffres très dur très
sûr donc si nous voulons surveiller
mieux ce variant il est absolument
indispensable aujourd'hui de faire ce
qu'a préconisé philippe raud gueule
c'est à dire de multiplier les
séquençages arn de souche de manière à
suivre de façon très très très proches
et avec une bonne certitude statistique
l'évolution du variant de manière à
éviter une mauvaise surprise qui
pourrait se jouer les casse en arriver à
partir du 15 août fin août
à cette époque là on pense que le
variant delta sera majoritaire en france
et on voit qu'en angleterre il a
multiplié par quatre le nombre de
contaminations en très peu de jours donc
il y à un danger dans un pays la france
qui ne sera vacciné qu'à 60%
probablement à la fin de l'été avec 40%
de non vaccinés il est possible qu'il y
ait une petite quatrième vague
philippe froguel effectivement vous êtes
un défenseur de ce séquençage de la
première heure même question quel rang
alexandre selon vous est ce que ça veut
dire qu'on a sous-estimé qu'on sous
estime déjà ce chiffre et que ça peut
aller très vite
le seul chiffre qu'on avait été
probablement juste c'est 1% vers le 25
mai c'était l'étude flash la dernière
qu'on a eu
moi j'avais calculé ou pour vérifier sur
mes tweets qu'on devrait être de l'ordre
de 9 à 10% en ce moment j'espère me
tromper mais c'est aujourd'hui le cas
j'ai aussi hélas se dit écrit que si ça
continue comme ça on aurait comme
l'angleterre le 22 mars à j'ai vérifié
et c'est vrai le 22 mai ils ont commencé
à réaugmenter le nombre de cas et ça
correspondait à 10% de variants donc le
10 % de monsieur attali
on ne pense pas que sais je sais pas
c'est vrai ou faux parce que je pense
qu'on n'a pas les moyens aujourd'hui
savoir la réalité mais le jour où on
aura réellement dit pourtant l'aca devra
augmenter ça pourrait en juillet début
juillet ou fin juillet selon la selon la
réalité des chiffres
le gouvernement est complètement aveugle
aujourd'hui on n'en sait absolument rien
tout ce qu'on sait c'est que comme
partout et comme manuel du nuage de
tchernobyl ça nous échappe pas à nous
comme de parce qu'on voit ce qui se
passe au portugal qui se passe en
allemagne reste en belgique
donc on aura une augmentation pour
savoir ce qui va se passer c'est très
simple il faut ré séquences et avoir un
un taux autant x et avoir un temps un
taux autant x + 7 jours et là on aura
une caisse pas 70
donc on a quoi ça bonjour madame soleil
depuis le temps qu'on en parle on se
demande pourquoi c'est pas encore bien
en place il faut séquence est davantage
vous me dis depuis longtemps regardé ce
tweet du professeur philippe juvin chef
de service urgences à l'hôpital pompidou
à paris le partage votre opinion
trois leçons à tirer vite de nos erreurs
passées il faut le surveiller en
séquençant comme le font nos voisins
accélérer la seconde dose de vaccin qui
protège traquer les cas isolé ces trois
pistes dans les landes
on rappelle à un cluster de variants
indien à dax 70% de contamination le
vaccin laurent alexandre clairement
est-il une des pistes les plus sérieuses
pour lutter contre ce variant il faut
aller plus vite dans la vaccination et
notamment la deuxième dose comme le
suggère le professeur jules 20
évidemment il y a toujours aucun
traitement
tout le monde reconnaît aujourd'hui que
l'ivermectine la chloroquine ne
fonctionne pas donc notre la seule arme
que nous avons ce sont les méthodes de
confinement qui ne sont pas durables et
puis la vaccination pour ce qui concerne
le variant delta on voit que la
protection est médiocre avec une seule
injection
donc lorsque le variant delta se
multiplient il est absolument crucial
qu'une partie importante de la
population et reçu les deux doses
d'autre part avec des variants qui sont
de plus en plus contaminant qui
diffusent de plus en plus vite
pour le dire simplement comme le marié
anglais puis maintenant le variant
indien le seuil nécessaire pour avoir
une immunité collective ils montent
mécaniquement donc aujourd'hui on est
très probablement pas à 60% de de
vacciner pour avoir une immunité
collective on est plus probablement
entre 80 et 85% qui sont nécessaires
or on voit bien que donc on a un vrai
plafond de verre dans la plupart des
pays occidentaux du fait des mouvements
complotistes anti vaccins et qu'on a
beaucoup de mal à dépasser 65 % même
israël qui a été le leader mondial de
l'acquis nation est aujourd'hui à 63% de
vaccination et ne progresse plus 1 ils
vont atteindre 64 65 maximum donc on
n'est pas suffisamment matinée il un
pool de 40 % de gens non vaccinés avec
un variant qui diffuse plus vite comme
le gardian delta et bien c'est le risque
d'avoir une nouvelle vague
alors est ce que il est difficile de
dire cette nouvelle vague va arriver dès
la fin de l'été ou si elle va attendre
septembre octobre
on est aujourd'hui dans une phase de
baisse de décélération fort per 0 est
tout à fait raisonnable
je parle de la france bien sûr là pas de
l'angleterre
on a des raisons d'optimisme mais les
données anglaises sont inquiétantes et
montre bien que avec les données
israélienne que la vaccination à 60 65 %
ne suffit pas pour casser l'épidémie
quand on a des variants qui diffuse vite
comme le delta injustement avant de
donner la parole à philippe froguel
on va s'arrêter justement quelques
instants sur cet exemple israélien où
malgré un vous l'avez dit laurent
alexandre la rapidité la campagne
vaccinale le nombre de cas de
contamination est en hausse avec
toujours en cause ce variant delta les
détails avec médecine romagnan
l'inquiétude des autorités israéliennes
face au co vide 19 essais variant au
lundi 125 nouveaux cas ont été
répertoriés
alors qu'on comptait seulement une
dizaine de cas quotidiens cette dernière
semaine
la faute aux variants delta importés en
israël par des voyageurs
plus de mille personnes ont dû être
placés en quarantaine après le retour
d'israéliens parti à chypre
le premier ministre naftali bennet
appelle les voyageurs à la prudence et à
porter de nouveau le masque si vous
savez éviter de partir en vacances à
l'étranger fait si vous n'avez pas
encore réservé je vous recommande de ne
pas le faire aliment blitz à la fois au
nom des experts forte on démasque de
nouveau en intérieur je demande aux
ministres et aux dirigeants à partir de
maintenant nous porteront des masques en
intérieur à l'obligation de porter le
masque dans les lieux publics fermés a
pris fin il ya seulement une semaine à
l'annoncé de la levée de cette mesure
des habitants de tel aviv s'était
montrée soulagée même si certains
restaient sceptiques
c'est génial on va au centre commercial
ont fait des courses et on n'a pas
besoin de porter de masque on peut
manger et boire sans rien sur le visage
donc c'est super on se sent très bien
[Musique]
c'est surtout effrayant de penser que la
morbidité va soudainement augmenté parce
que le nombre de masques à diminuer en
tant que médecin je fais confiance aux
autorités
je les ai cru durant toute cette période
car je n'ai aucune raison de ne pas le
faire tout d'abord on se sent libre mais
je pense que dans les bus il faudrait
quand même porter un masque car il ya
plus de monde dans les centres
commerciaux c'est parfait et on sent
qu'on reprend une vie normale
la vaccination a été ouverte aux
adolescents de 12 à 16 ans en israël le
6 juin dernier
naftali bennett a appelé les parents à
les faire vacciner le plus vite possible
les 10-19 ans ont été les plus touchées
par le virus ce mois ci plus de la
moitié de la population israélienne a
déjà reçu deux doses du c'est romantique
au vide
malgré cette récente hausse des nouveaux
cas le nombre de décès de lui reste très
limité avec 1 seulement recensés ce
mardi philippe froguel plein
d'enseignements dans ce sujet déjà des
contaminations qui repartent à la hausse
on reparle de restrictions on s'inquiète
mais surtout on y serait n'ont réagi
quand même de manière très rapide et de
manière significative est ce que c'est
la bonne méthode ils vont s'en sortir et
est ce qu'on n'a pas un petit peu un
train de retard en europe tout cas il ya
des choses que fois il revient qu'on n'a
pas osé fait en france ou en belgique ce
qui a fait que par exemple si vous êtes
un soignant a et il faut absolument que
vous soyez vacciner sinon vous êtes viré
de votre hôpital alors en france je l'
ai vu à au nord de la france on l'a vu
en belgique et des ehpad avec des gens
qui sont morts alors qu'ils étaient
vaccinés tout simplement parce que les
soignants ne l'était pas donc il faut
qu'un jour en europe aura on considère
ce qu'il faut faire
le prix à payer est le prix à payer
c'est que tout le monde soit vacciné et
qu'on arrête d
pcdt dû avoir des gens qui sont des
soignants et qui a un je ne sais pas
pourquoi
décide que eux ils ont le droit de
contaminer des gens âgés qui vous sont à
risque et là c'est quelque chose d'un
état normal donc je pense que les
israéliens font ce qu'ils doivent faire
et on va voir s'ils vont réussir à
échapper à avoir des morts et des gens
l'hôpital avec ce variant delta qui
n'ont rappelons le est extrêmement
extrêmement contagieux et on veut voir
si j'y arrive effectivement ça soit très
indicatif des choses qu'il faudrait
faire en europe
alors alors alexandre matin s'auto
flageller parce que pour le moment comme
l'a souligné le professeur froguel on
sait pas encore si ça va marcher en
israël et on leur souhaite évidemment et
tout comme on nous le souhaite en europe
mais on a quand même le sentiment chaque
fois que l'europe voilà et et peine à
prendre des mesures très fortes et là je
met l'europe on entière dans le même
panier on n'a pas fermé les frontières
très vite avec l'inde à commencer par le
royaume-uni il faut frapper vite et fort
dès maintenant on ça sera trop tard dans
un mois
c'est compliqué les français sortent à
peine du confinement ils en ont un
on est à moins d'un an de l'élection
présidentielle donc emmanuel macron ne
peut pas être trop castrateur parce que
si les castrateur il va perdre
l'élection présidentielle qui n'est pas
gagné pour lui donc on est dans une
configuration politique qui est
compliqué les français en ont
objectivement marc mais c'est pareil
ailleurs c'est pareil chez moi en
belgique
donc il va être difficile de mettre en
place des mesures autoritaires dès cet
été au moment où les gens veulent au
contraire relâché la pression je suis
d'accord avec philippe gall là le fait
que les soignants ne soit pas vaccinés
et suffisamment est scandaleux il y
effectivement des gens qui sont
contaminés par les soignants non
vaccinés et qui meurent du coc vide et
c'est inacceptable la vaccination doit
être obligatoire pour tous les soignants
quel que soit quelle que soit leur
catégorie et puis il ya un autre
problème inacceptable en france c'est
que si l'on prend les gens de plus de 80
sanguin à 22% qui ne sont pas vaccinées
en france
c'est absolument inacceptable que les
gens qui ont un risque massif de mourir
ducobu
ne soient vaccinés qu'à 78 79 % en
france et là je parle de la première
injection
c'est un scandale laurent alexandre jeu
je pense je pense qu'il faut rendre la
vaccination obligatoire au dessus de 70
ans parce que le pourcentage de gens à
risque qui n'est pas vacciné aujourd'hui
est beaucoup trop important la
vaccination des enfants et des ados est
un problème difficile et très très
compliqué et et on aurait pu on aurait
besoin de trop de temps pour en discuter
en revanche l'obligation vaccinale au
delà de 70 ans et chez les soignants est
une nécessité pour éviter cette
quatrième vague
franchement aujourd'hui d'avoir 22 % de
jambes plus de 80 ans non vaccinés on
déconne à plein tube
c'est inacceptable et c'est absolument
scandaleux c'est en termes de santé
publique une énorme erreur et là dessus
le gouvernement a été trop laxiste
parce que il ne l a voulu donner des
gages aux complotistes anti-vaccins il a
flatté
il a flatté les anti vaccins aujourd'hui
il faut rendre obligatoire sur ces deux
catégories de population le vaccin c'est
inévitable sinon on va être à nouveau en
bété à la rentrée en tout cas le centre
européen de prévention et de contrôle
des maladies on nous annonce ce soir que
ce variant indien devrait représenter
90% des nouveaux cas dans l'union
européenne d'ici la fin autant cesser
demain la fin août clairement fini
problème ça ça va nous pourrir la fin de
l'été et surtout la rentrée tout dépend
du taux de vaccination si les français
font ce qu'ils ne font pas aujourd'hui
viennent une prévost diminution du
nombre de pros de primo vacciner
puisqu'on n'est plus qu'à 2 à 300 milles
par jour à est en fait la plupart des
vaccinés sont c'est utile bien entendu
d'aider les gens qu'on leur deuxième
dose mais il ya un plafond de verre et
on connaît tous des gens pauvres
guettant un jeune qui refuse à se faire
vacciner c'est ça c'est absolument
dramatique
moi si j'étais le gouvernement je ferai
une une campagne extrêmement agressive
pour pousser tout le monde à se faire
vacciner c'est à peu près la seule chose
qu'on peut faire en réalité parce qu'il
est tellement con
tabiou le reste ça va balayer tout si on
dit et qu'il y aura 90 % de variants à
la fin août
on voit bien que quoi qu'on fasse on n'y
échappera pas donc si on veut pas que
des gens qui meurent et qui se retrouve
à l'hôpital où des gens qui est des
coville l'on est quand même 10 % après
covin l'on a laissé les gens sont très
gênés à y ait une étude qui vient de
sortir qui monte quand même des
anomalies au niveau du cerveau de pas
mal de gens qui ont eu des idées déco
vite donc on sait pas trop ce que c'est
ce que c'est au long terme il faut
vacciner vacciner vacciner et je ne
trouve qu'en france on est un petit peu
encore le vaccin
voyez les les les films c'est encore le
vaccin de la personne âgée vulnérable il
faut que tout le monde se vaccine mais
le royaume uni laurent alexandra fille
pour qu'elle le connaît bien puisqu'il y
travaillent
également on voit que tu as eue
voilà il ya ce plafond de verre est
présent aussi au royaume uni qui a
pourtant une autre politique c'est un
problème qui est globale il n'y a pas
qu'en france qui a des complotistes
anti-vaccins il y en a partout
on a une vraie difficulté on a 20 à 30%
de la population qui a été convaincu par
des gens comme alexandra environ coude
associé à bigard à lalanne que le vaccin
est très dangereux allait modifier notre
adn allait dans certains cas nous tuer
on a vu à nos confrères marseillais
expliqué que vacciner les personnes
âgées
cette tête organisé un génocide
donc on a un certain nombre de médecins
onega qui ont tenu des propositions
sectaire complotistes anti-vaccins
complètement dingue est complètement
folle il n'y a pas eu
y a pas eu de mouvements du gouvernement
pour lutter contre ces complotistes fou
et très très dangereux qui sont entraîne
convaincu une partie de la population
qui ne faut pas se faire vacciner
donc il est indispensable de lutter
contre les complotistes anti vaccins et
de rendre obligatoire la vaccination
pour les catégories dont j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure et d'inciter fortement les
autres catégories à se faire vacciner
rapidement parce que le philippe a tout
à fait raison
à l'heure actuelle on est en train de
tourner à 200 milles primo vaccinés par
jour ça veut dire qu'on est au plafond
de verre et qu'on va pas dépasser 60 2
65% en france or avec le variant delta
ça ne va pas passer ce n'est pas
suffisant avec le variant delta le petit
mot de la fin pour vous filer programmes
majeurs je suis d'accord il y avait rien
à dire de plus si les français ne sont
pouvoir ne se font pas vacciner plus on
va avoir des ennuis et on n'aura
peut-être pas énormément plus de bord
mais on aura des gens commandent et
corinne longue qui vont souffrir
et pourquoi souffrir alors qu'on sait
comment l'éviter il faut avoir deux
doses de vaccins particulièrement des
vaccins arn il peut moderna ou pfizer
et on est quand même extrêmement protégé
à quoi pas de là le faire c'est
complètement stupide
merci en tout cas tous les cas merci
infiniment fini progrès laurent
alexandre d'avoir été avec nous en
direct pour ce décryptage